i really want to keep cycling more i
feel really fit
yeah yeah i mean i mean
if you don't feel fit after this i don't
know what's going on
because like your heart rate is like
literally
it's just elevated all day long like
you're just purely exercising like
seven eight hours a day yeah that's it
for eight days no breaks it's probably
terrible if you actually want to build
muscle and actually do it healthily uh
but yeah it's great to lose body fat if
you want to lose weight it's great but i
wouldn't recommend it it's just like
it's i mean it's pretty it's like it's
like not eating for three days yeah it's
awful because like you know you're
burning
like i don't know i think most days you
were burning like five four thousand
calories a day so it's like oh it's on
top of your daily like 2000 yeah yeah
yeah yeah so you're just like there's no
possible way you can eat 8 000 calories
a day
like unless you're like actually trying
your hardest yeah yeah yeah yeah i just
didn't want to eat i don't cycling i
don't want to [ __ ] eat yeah it's i
mean like it's i mean i think it's a
great way to lose weight if you want to
like [ __ ]
do that i mean i don't think i lost that
much weight because i was also i was
drinking a lot of beer
well that made the beer worth it though
right that was that's the sweet you're
putting back the 8000 calories like like
10 pints of beer yeah well i i mean i
ate i ate as much as i could
at every point but yeah there's even
then it's like you just
i don't know if only we had our health
checkup right now right corner know yeah
that was the real increase it was just
like [ __ ] my health jacob's coming up
somewhere
eight days later but then like it's like
you you finish it like five
six pm every day and then got a shower
yeah yeah yeah and then i have to charge
everything right i have to charge the
like uh the giant portable portable
battery have to charge all the router uh
router which is a british form
i call it i don't know which one it is
it's it's pretty rooted i say router i
i've heard i don't say hey i don't think
people say router so maybe it's the
american one i have to charge all i feel
like i feel like router's like the
southern christmas maybe yeah maybe
you know
i have to like charge my my phone my
stream phone uh the two portable
batteries in my bike
the uh the giant battery uh the
three
routers um
everything else and then i have to put
it all back in the bike and it's just
it's a lot every day yeah yeah you
probably pretty much didn't get to do
anything for like eight days well i mean
like was there anywhere you'd want to go
back to and oh yeah like nobody bet 2
was cool
it's a really famous onsen town yeah ah
and that was really cool
because a lot of the towns you went to
just had nothing
just nothing in there yeah i think it
was three days we didn't see anything
yeah i feel like anything north of like
sub-par is
like there were some places that only
had
like one hotel within like a uh you know
like an 80 kilometer radius yeah yeah
yeah like um
uh i'm sure
chris can tell the story about this
racist hotel staff but there's already
clips of it and stuff not racist i don't
know [ __ ] or maybe just a horrible
person
with everyone
i mean i don't know if they're just
racist or they're just horrible
that's that's the difficulty of being in
traffic especially in like the country
in japan are you being racist or are you
just like
i'm not talking about i don't know i
can't tell
like there was like you know uh the
first night there was like no hotels in
this area just none right it was just
only like one hostel
and it just like didn't make sense for
us to go in a hostel when we had to
charge charge everything yeah yeah it'd
be up so early and we going to get there
so late and stuff so it was just it was
just tough
really tough i don't know
how
you would would you would you do it
again
like some something like that cycle not
hokkaido again
hokkaido is way harder than anywhere
else in japan somewhere a little more
like with a little more civilization i'd
love to do it uh i mean crystal's also
chris already already was like maybe we
should do another one sometime soon
i mean i don't mind
yeah i i the idea was like maybe kyushu
or something right that makes more sense
right because it's a whole island yeah
yeah it's a lot hillier though yeah but
then apparently chris was telling me
there's a there's another way this is
like the west or east side that's not as
hilly or whatever i don't like hill same
famous last words yeah it's like i'm
fine
it was like way more successful than i
thought yeah i thought it wasn't gonna
be i thought the viewership on my twitch
was not gonna be as good as it was yeah
um i thought because he was like i
thought i wouldn't like watch it if i
just watched someone cycle i don't know
i mean i feel like irl content on twitch
she's just doing really really well
right now definitely
uh because no one else can come to japan
that's why so that's their only that's
literally the only way they would just
create their needs it's great you could
just show off a [ __ ] combination like
chat look at that
i think irl stuff should always be like
an event not i don't know how you could
be uh like i don't know how rob does it
uh robert i don't know how rob does he
streams like five days a week yeah i i
really like i don't know how those like
how have you not run out of places to go
yeah i don't know how he does it i yeah
i would be
sick of going outside yeah i would just
touching too much grass
i'm like can i can i not touch grass
i think it's great to have irl stream
events i think as one-offs they're
really good and i think twitch right now
or streaming in general like irl is a
really big uh like trend right yeah yeah
there's always been a thing but i think
right now it's particularly popular than
anything yeah definitely um when it's
done well yeah um so if you want to try
it try it it just sucks because the
barrier of entry to irl streaming is
very very high well yeah um also cycling
as well
on top of it if you want to get into
like the amount of cycling that you did
like you don't need to buy all the [ __ ]
that i bought like you could get a [ __ ]
bike and do the same thing it would just
be harder oh yeah like this bike wasn't
would you have a good time though during
your stream
this bike was my bike was nutty i've
never had gears that changed like that
like i've never had a bike where you
just tap it boom change gear
immediately no questions asked the bike
is like bra i got you doesn't matter
what hell you're on anything boom tap it
you want to go two hold it down twice as
long it's insane i've never had so now
so now that you've had the cycling
experience what do you think makes a
good bike
what would you recommend now that you're
a cycling expert
now that you're uh you know that you're
the traveler's
like this bike and this bike was nuts
like i i don't understand how people can
like review bikes for a living i'm just
like what are you what are you looking
for like i feel like every bike is
slightly i feel like you can say that
with any niche though yeah i wanted a
bike that was good for the lazy man uh
because mine had a thing so you got you
you got the apple of bikes
kinda i i kind of got like the like yeah
like the full so i bought my bike purely
on the reason that
it had um the headlights and the rear
light like built into the bike right and
then you just charge this battery pack
on the
frame and then it's just controlled by
an app no you just turn the lights on or
if it gets dark they automatically turn
on
easy and i was like cool that sounds
good because i hate turning on these
lights i always forget to send them off
and then i just i'm i understand that
this is such a lazy reason to get it but
i just wanted to do it turns out it
became a pain at one point because when
i had no internet i couldn't turn my
lights on oh
there's no there's no way to turn them
on
without an hour and it really felt like
that moment where boomers are like
why do you why you gotta put technology
in everything we did we we had lights
that work just fine without these
[ __ ] apps yeah why do you need smart
balls when their switches are they truly
felt at that point where it was like ah
this sucks this is so dumb why does that
why is there not a way for this this is
an oversight
there's no way for me to turn it on
without the app yeah this is [ __ ]
dumb yeah when when the when the
inevitable rogue ai you know take starts
taking over humanity yeah we're gonna
look back at this point and be like why
can't we turn on the lights without our
[ __ ] smart tap so you're gonna pay
like 10 10 bezos bucks
play a subscription service yeah
oh my god so i bought this bike so i
said four thousand dollars but i think
it's normally four thousand dollars i
don't know what the [ __ ] happened but
yeah um i went to the store when i
because i already knew what bike i
wanted and they had it in the store
because i i i didn't understand how how
you buy bikes really i just thought oh
they'll just have the bike in the store
yeah turns out like
like if the store's small they don't
have your bike they have to order it for
you which can take months yeah so i was
like chris i was like you by the way you
can't just like wait you should go now
yeah yeah so he waited like two weeks
before and couldn't get the same bike as
me but he wanted the same bike as me
right um so he couldn't get that one
because he
he the store he had didn't have it but
luckily i went to the store and they had
it and i had it in like shining purple
and i was like oh [ __ ] sick yeah
trash tastes represent
yeah i got it
and um yeah it was really weird it was
like
um three thousand dollars and for some
reason the day that i went to the store
they had a campaign on was like yeah you
get
uh 10 off
uh the bike just pick any bike just
because
and then i got extra money off because i
paid in cash and it ended up costing
like 2 500 bucks and i was like oh okay
cool not too bad then um i was like
sweet i've got these apps and stuff is
that is that not too bad that's 500 off
i mean i paid for the insurance
hey it is this is a good buy this is a
good buy
it's still a two thousand dollar bike it
is an amazing bike it is a it's a
beautiful non-cyclist be like that it is
carbon fiber a beautiful specimen i'm
like damn i like and the first bike i
bought was like 150 i was like oh that's
[ __ ] expensive
it was god tier dude it was like perfect
yeah you do not need a goodbye to this i
definitely like just just because i had
the money i just splurged yeah that's
purely like a you do not need this kind
of mic right um so yeah and then i
bought the bike and i started sweating
when i when i went to the app store to
download the app and i saw the reviews
and it had 2.1 stars and i was like
it's not going to work
yeah and i've been trying to update my
sensor in the bike for like a month now
i can't update it just doesn't work just
doesn't let me update it damn can't
update my bike the lights
they turn on but they're so finicky
right it's so annoying i'm just like i
for [ __ ] sake why would they not just
put a button to turn it on
like this is an
expensive we're going real we're going
real minimalistic with our design an
expensive bike and this the lights are a
pain in the [ __ ] ass to turn on yeah
they put all these like bits and bobs on
a bike but they were like switch for the
lights which no no we don't need a
switch i also like you know i might the
seat on the bike you know i assume if
i'm the super most serious cyclist on
earth it's great
it's just not comfortable it is tiny
it's tiny is there air is there does is
there any bike that actually has a
comfortable seat for road bikes
generally they're not yeah they're not
they're like really small and they're
meant to you know because your cyclists
are like all right get used to it that's
kind of what it is you just have to you
literally just have to destroy your ass
yeah yeah
yeah and i was like can i change the
seats we you know i take the seat off
and i'm like oh
yeah the the rear headlight that is
hardwired to the bike cannot be removed
from this
seat so i have no choice but to use the
seat right that's how they rope you into
it
so i have to buy like this padded suit
but i really wanted this bike
right because it was perfect for what i
wanted it was like an endurance bike and
the wheels were a bit thicker than
normal road bikes and it was just it was
good god he did buy the apple bikes he
did [ __ ]
no accessories no customization yeah
everything is included i imagine like
trying to fix this bike is a pain yeah
um you're gonna probably have to call up
like that particularly
you break the warranty you have to have
like specialist equipment i gotta do the
most simplest thing two year warranty
cost me 600 [ __ ] dollars to for
insurance and [ __ ] on this bike
i had to
register with the police as you do in
japan oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
because it's like it's like it's
considered a vehicle registration in
japan yeah yeah and
yeah that's why getting rid of a bike as
well is [ __ ] pain in the air oh i
don't want to get rid of this you can't
just like yeah but like if you if you
were to for whatever reason it's the
biggest pain in the ass i remember when
i got rid of my bike it was like a whole
like
like three week process just like call
them up and be like i want to get rid of
this bike and then you have to do all
this paperwork to like unregister the
bike and then you have to get rid of the
bike which costs you know well luckily i
think this bike's nice enough where i
could probably just sell it oh yeah i
don't think i will i mean i love this
bike this bike's awesome yeah i really
wanna
you know eventually cycle around like
europe or something
well now that you've invested this much
money into it it's it would be a shame
if you didn't use it again i mean i you
know i've been cycling to the before the
self-cycling to the studio a lot i loved
it i think it's dude
after cycling on this bike it's like oh
this is like
how cycling is supposed to feel
like
cycling in the shin amikaido and
recycling right you're doing these
uphills it feels like the bike is just
like not doing anything yeah yeah you
like square wheels it's just like you
pedal and it feels like nothing's
happening well that's that's why
a lot of the times we just ended up
walking up the hills yeah because it
felt like less effort you know i think i
was actually moving faster because like
the energy the energy you're putting
into each pedal like wasn't translating
is like what you kind of wanted yeah
whereas like with this bike like it was
just like every like rotation you put
into it felt like it went
directly into pushing you because it's
such a nice bike and it's so good and it
was crazy like up hills man i've never
had anything like that it felt like
you're slowly walking up a hill right
because the on the lowest lowest gear it
was basically like walking up a hill
it's crazy it's such a good bike
we're this is this is now the connor
cyclist arc we have now entered everyone
i just can't believe that i thought the
shin nami cardo is hard like that's
that's like maybe maybe we just nerfed
ourselves we should do it again and then
i'll just be like all right guys boys i
finished three hours
yeah i'm glad you did the cycling
special now and so after this
you know that little cat and mouse race
thing we did i'm sure on this bike it
would have been like i'd have [ __ ]
zoomed past oh yeah not even
like this bike is nutty i just it's i
didn't realize how good these road bikes
obviously if you're a better cyclist
you'll you're still like you know you'll
be able to use it more of course like i
never did the
just because i i couldn't be bothered um
because it was just pain in the ass you
know where you can go right on the
bottom handlebars and be more wind yes
resistant i never wanted to go that fast
uh and i and also it was horrible for
the camera angle yeah so i'll just be
pointing at the ground so i never ever
did that
um so i wasn't really using the bike for
it's like full potential if you will i'm
sure cyclists are like cringy potential
you know what i mean because like it's
some super saiyan bites
the weather conditions bro i i thought
rain was the worst turns out no wind is
the worst right wind wind is number one
can [ __ ] off when you're playing well
that's literally why like professional
cyclists in the olympics they have like
they literally have a [ __ ] team you
know it's it's it's it's so interesting
the the
wind is like
it can make downhills feel like flats if
it's strong enough and it's crazy you'll
be going on the flat and you'll be you
you'll have to put the same amount of
energy as going up a hill just to keep
going yeah because the wind will be so
crazy
it's i just was like [ __ ] this like if
if this was this every day i would i
couldn't do it yeah
we got so lucky that one or two days
were perfect we had rain some days which
is miserable because your feet get like
trench foot yeah and you're just soaked
it's just should have hired someone just
like tank the wind for you like like an
olympics i was following chris a lot of
the time because
he he did a good job of that yeah he did
it because chris i don't know why chris
got that yeah he's not patient he just
wanted to go in front of me
it's like all right i don't know it was
it was good i mean when there was like
certain days where i
felt like i could just keep cycling till
the end of time right we did like 120k
one day which is the longest day and at
the end of it i just felt like yeah i
could do another 50 another 60. i felt
totally like good to go nice i don't
know why some days you just feel it and
other days you're like holy [ __ ] 10k is
so hard yeah um i don't know it's i feel
like that's true with exercise in
general though you know yeah it sucks
because when you do something like this
those days where you would normally wake
up and be like no hell hell i won't do
exercise today yeah yeah yeah
it's not gonna happen cause you you know
those days where you talk to the gym and
you just you just you're just [ __ ] just
everything the walk to the gym you just
like oh you're you're leaving you know
you know this day is going to suck you
start running on the treadmill after two
minutes you're like [ __ ] i can't yeah
you you can't even do your like normal
reps yeah like everything's [ __ ] it's
just like that but like in cycling form
and you're like
like i wouldn't even be tired but my
muscles like my leg muscles would be
just so [ __ ] that i just couldn't get
them to pedal the speed i wanted them to
go to right whereas other days it would
be just easy like i could just maintain
like a crazy pace all day don't know why
and yeah it was it was awesome like it
just kind of depended on a lot of
factors i don't know why like i i'm like
some days i would like
like the day after sapporo i had drank
in sapporo so much beer like i had like
six or seven pints of beer
because i was like i'm in sapporo baby i
gotta
and then that was like my best cycling
day the day after
i just i'd killed it like i just i was
on fire cured by
yeah probably i mean it's because every
day i had like two beers after it right
yeah i don't have a beer of course yeah
you wanted it
that was rough
that's empowered me yeah and yeah